what is the role of a difficult
childhood in the lives of great men and
women great minds is that a requirement
is it a catalyst or is it just a simple
Coincidence of Fate well it's not a
requirement some people with happy
childhood to do quite well but it
certainly is true that a lot of really
driven people are driven because they're
harnessing the Demons of their childhood
even Barack Obama's uh sentence and his
Memoirs which is I think every
successful man is either trying to live
up to the expectations of of his father
or live down the sins of his father and
for Elon it's especially true because he
had both a violent and difficult
childhood and a very psychologically
problematic father
he's got those demons uh dancing around
in his head and by harnessing them it's
part of the reason that he does riskier
more adventurous Wilder things and maybe
I would ever do you've written that Elon
talked about his father and that at
times it felt like mental torture the
the interaction with him during his
childhood can you describe some of the
things you've learned yeah well Elon and
Kimball would tell me that for example
when Elon got bullied on the playground
and one day was pushed down some
concrete steps and had his face pummeled
so badly that Kimball said I couldn't
really recognize him and he was in the
hospital for almost a week but when he
came home Elon had to stand in front of
his father and his father berated him
for more than an hour and said he was
stupid and took the side of the of the
person who had beaten him that's
probably one of the more traumatic
events of elon's Life yes and there's
also veld school which is a sort of
paramilitary camp that young South
African boys got sent to and at one
point you know he was scrawny he has
very bad at picking up social cues and
emotional cues he talks about being
Asperger's and so he gets uh traumatized
at a camp like that but the second time
time he went he'd gotten bigger he had
shot up to almost six feet and he
learned a little bit of Judo and he
realized that if he was getting beaten
up he might it might hurt him but he
would just punch the person in the nose
as hard as possible so that sense of
always punching back has also been
ingrained in Elon I spent a lot of time
talking Arrow musk his father Elon done
talked to Meryl musk anymore his father
nor does Kimball it's been years and uh
Errol doesn't even have elon's email so
a lot of times Arrow will be sending me
emails and Errol had one of those Jekyll
and Hyde personalities he was you know a
great mind of engineering and especially
Material Science I knew how to build a
Wilderness Camp in South Africa using
Micah and how it would not conduct the
heat but he also would go into these
dark periods in which he would just be
psychologically abusive and of course
May musk says to me the his mother who
divorced Daryl early on said the danger
for Elon is that he becomes his father
and every now and then you've been with
him so much LAX and you know him well
he'll even talk to you about the demons
about Diablo dancing in his head I mean
he he gets it he's self-aware but you've
probably seen him at times where those
demons take over and he goes really dark
and really quiet and uh Grimes
says you know I can tell a minute or two
in advance when demon Mode's about to
happen and he'll go a bit dark I was you
know here at Austin wanted dinner with a
group
and you could tell suddenly something
had triggered him and he was going to go
dark I've watched it in meetings where
somebody will say we can't make that
part for less than 200 or no that's
wrong and he'll berate them and then he
steps out of it as you know that too the
the huge snap out where suddenly he's
showing you Monty pythons get on his
phone he's joking about things so I
think coming out of the childhood there
were just mini facets maybe even many
personalities the engineering mode the
silly mode the charismatic mode the
Visionary mode but also the demon in
dark mode I'll quote you cited about
elon's really stood out to me I forget
uh who was from but inside the man he's
still there as a child the child's
standing in front of his dad that was
Tallulah his second wife
and she's great uh she's an English
actress they've been married twice
actually and Tallulah said that's just
him from his childhood he's a drama
addict Kimball says that as well
and
I asked why and he said and Tallulah
said
you know for him love and family are
kind of associated with those
psychological torments and in many ways
he'll Channel I mean Tallulah would be
with him in
2008 when the company was going back or
whatever it may have been or later
and he would be so stressed he would
vomit and then he would Channel things
that his father had said use phrase as
his father had said to him
and so she told me deep inside the man
is this man-child still standing in
front of his father
to a degree is that true for many of us
do you think
I think it's true but in many different
ways I'll say something personal which
is I was blessed and perhaps it's a bit
of a downside too but the fact that I
had the greatest father he could ever
imagine and mother they were the kindest
people you'd ever want to meet I grew up
in a magical place in New Orleans my dad
was an engineer an electrical engineer
and
you know he was always kind
perhaps
I'm not quite as driven or as crazed I
don't have to prove things so I get to
write about Elon Musk I get to write
about you know Einstein or Steve Jobs or
Leonardo da Vinci who as you know was
totally torn by demons and had different
difficult childhood situations not even
legitimized by his father so sometimes
those of us who are lucky enough to have
really gentle sweet childhood
we grew up with fewer demons but we grow
up with fewer drives and we end up maybe
being Boswell and not being Dr Johnson
we end up being the Observer not being
the doer and so I always respect those
who are in the arena I don't you know
you don't see yourself as a man in the
arena I've had a gentle sweet career
and I've got to cover really interesting
people but I've never shot off a rocket
that might someday get to Mars I've
never moved us into the era of electric
vehicles I've never stayed up all night
on the factory floor
I don't have quite
those
either the drives or the
uh addiction to risk I mean elon's
addicted to risk he's addicted to
Adventure
me if I see something that's risky I
spend some time calculating okay upside
downside here uh but that's another
reason that people like Elon Musk get
stuff done
and people like me write about the Elon
musks one other aspect of this given a
difficult childhood whether it's Elon or
da Vinci
I wonder if there's some wisdom
some advice almost that you can draw
that you can give to people with
difficult childhoods I think all of us
have demons even those of us who grew up
in a magical part of New Orleans with
sweet parents yes and we all have demons
and
rule one in life is harness your demons
know that you're ambitious or not
ambitious or you're lazy or whatever
uh Leonardo da Vinci knew he was a
procrastinator you know I think
it's usual to know what's eating at you
know how to harness it
um
also know what you're good at I'll take
musk as another example
I'm a little bit more like Kimball musk
than Elon I maybe got over endowed with
the empathy Gene and what does that mean
well it means that I was okay when I ran
Time Magazine it was a group about a 150
people on the editorial floors and I
knew them all and we had a jolly time
when I went to CNN I was not very good
at being a manager or an executive of an
organization
uh I cared a little bit too much that
people didn't get annoyed at me or
um mad at me and Elon said that about
John McNeil for example who was
president of Tesla it's in the book I
talked to John McNeil a long time and he
says uh you know Elon just would fire
people be really rough on people he
didn't have the empathy for the people
in front of him and Elon says yeah
that's right and John McNeil couldn't
fire people he cared more about pleasing
the people in front of him than pleasing
the entire Enterprise or getting things
done being over endowed with a desire to
please people can make you less tough of
a manager and uh that doesn't mean there
aren't great people over in doubt Ben
Franklin over endowed with the desire to
please people the worst criticism of him
from John Adams and others was that he
was insinuating which kind of meant he
was always trying to get people to like
him uh but that turned out to be a good
thing when they can't figure out the big
state little State issue at the
Constitutional Convention when they
can't figure out the Treaty of Paris
whatever it is he brings people together
and that is his superpower so to get
back to the lessons you asked and you
know the first was harness your demons
the second is to know your strengths and
your superpower
my superpower is definitely not being a
tough manager after running CNN for a
while I said okay I think I've proven I
don't really enjoy this or know how to
do this well
uh you know do I have other talents yeah
I think out of the talent to observe
people really closely
to write about it in a straight but I
hope interesting narrative style that's
a power it's totally different from
running an organization it took me until
three years of running CNN that I
realized I'm not cut to be an executive
in a really
High intense
situations Elon Musk is cut to be an
executive in highly intense situation so
much so that when things get less
intense when they actually are making
enough cars and
Rockets are going up and Landing
he thinks of something else so he can
Surge and have more intensity he's
addicted to intensity
um
and that's his superpower which is a lot
greater than the superpower of being a
good Observer but I think also
uh to build on that it's not just
addiction
to like Risk and drama there's always a
big mission
above it so I would say uh it's an
empathy towards
people in the big picture
it's an empathy towards Humanity
Humanity more than the empathy towards
the three or four humans who might be
sitting in the conference room with you
and that's a big deal and you see that
in a lot of people you see it uh Bill
Gates or Larry Summers uh
Elon Musk
they always have empathy for these great
goals of humanity
and at times they can be clueless about
the emotions of the people in front of
them or callous sometimes
musk as you said
is driven by Mission more than any
person I've ever seen
and it's not only Mission it's like
Cosmic missions meaning he's got three
really big missions
one is to make humans a space-faring
civilization make us multi-planetary or
get us to Mars
number two is to bring us into the era
of sustainable energy to bring us into
the era of electric vehicles and solar
roofs and um battery packs and third is
to make sure that artificial
intelligence is safe and is aligned with
human values and every now and then I'd
talk to them and we'd be talking about
starlinks satellites or whatever or he
would be pushing the people in front of
him in SpaceX and saying if you do this
we'll never get to Mars in our lifetime
and then he would give the lecture how
important it was for human consciousness
to get to Mars in our lifetime and I'm
thinking okay this is the pep talk of
somebody trying to inspire a team or
maybe it's a type of of uh pontification
you do on a podcast but on like the 20th
time I watched them I realized okay I
believe it he actually is driven by this
his frustrated and angry that because of
this particular minor engineering
decision
the big mission is not going to be
accomplished it's not a pep talk it's a
literal frustration
and impatience of frustration
and um
it's also
just probably the most deeply ingrained
thing in him is his mission he joked at
one point to me about how much he loved
reading comics as a kid and he said all
the people in the comic books they're
trying to save the world but they're
wearing their underpants on the outside
and they look ridiculous and then he
paused and said but they are trying to
save the world and whether it's starlink
in Ukraine or Starship going to Mars or
trying to get a global new Tesla I think
he's got this epic sense of the role
he's going to play in helping Humanity
on big things
and like the the characters in the comic
books it's sometimes ridiculous but it
also is sometimes true
when I was reading this part of the book
I was thinking of all the young people
who are struggling in this way and I
think a lot of people are in different
ways whether they grow up without a
father whether they grow up with
physical emotional mental abuse or
Demons of any kind as you talked about
and it's really painful to read but also
really damn inspiring
that if you
sort of
walk side by side with those demons if
you don't let that pain break you
or somehow Channel it if you can put it
this way that you can achieve you can do
great things in this world well that's
um an epic view of why we write
biography which is more epic than I'd
even thought of so I say thank you
because in some ways what you're trying
to do is say okay
I mean Leonardo you talk about being a
misfit he's born illegitimate in the
village of Vinci and he's gay and he's
left-handed and he's distracted
and his father won't legitimize him
and uh
then he wanders off to the town of
Florence and he becomes the greatest
artist and engineer of the early
Renaissance of that part of the
Renaissance
I hope this book inspires Jennifer
Dowden of the gene editing Pioneer who
discovers helps discover crispr Gene
Eddington which my book The Code Breaker
she grew up feeling like a misfit you
know in Hawaii in a Polynesian Village
being the only white person
and also trying to live up to a father
who pushed her so if people can read the
books
and I should have said about Jennifer
dad and my point was that she was told
by her school guidance counselor no
girls don't do science you know science
not for girls you're not going to do
math or science and so it pushes her to
say all right I'm gonna do math and
science it's just to interrupt real
quick but uh Jennifer Donna you've
written an amazing book about her uh
Nobel Prize winner crisper developers
just incredible one of the great
scientists in the 21st century right and
I'm talking about when Jennifer Downton
was young and she felt really really out
of place like you and me and a lot of
people when they feel in that way they
read books they go into they curl up
with the book so her father drops a book
on her bed called the double helix the
book by James Watson on the discovery of
the structure of DNA by him and Rosalind
Franklin and Francis Crick and
she realizes oh my God girls can become
scientists my school guidance counselor
is wrong
so I think
books
like she read this book and even if it's
a comic book like Elon Musk read
books can sometimes inspire you
and every one of my books is about
people who are totally Innovative who
weren't just smart because none of us
are going to be able to match Einstein
and mental processing power but we can
be as curious as he was and creative and
think out of the box the way he did or
Steve Jobs put it think different and so
I hope with my books I'm saying
uh this isn't a how-to guide but this is
somebody you can walk alongside you can
see
Einstein growing up Jewish in Germany
you can see Jennifer doudner growing up
or as an outsider or a Leonardo da Vinci
or Elon Musk you know in really violent
South Africa with a psychologically
difficult father and getting off the
train when he goes to any apartheid
concert with his brother and there's a a
man with a knife sticking out of his
head and they step into the pool of
blood and it's sticky on their souls
this causes
you know scars that last the rest of
your life
and the question is not how do you avoid
getting scarred it's you know how do you
deal with it